this is a production of Cornell
University hello my name is keny
Rodriguez I am a PhD student at Cornell
and I'm with Steve Riner a professor of
horiculture and the Statewide vegetable
specialist at Corell and today we'll
talk about a practice that is usually
done in curits but we don't know if it
is the right practices so Ste whenever
we have a disease like downo people
think of pruning their plants do you
think this is a good practice and how is
it done sure
there there's been a lot of chatter
about this in gardening websites
recently about going out and pruning
your your squash your your zucchini so
we've got some plants here now these are
actually in really good shape but the
idea of pruning would be that you want
to just leave the sort of newer growth
that's coming out you can see that right
in here so you don't want to touch that
but it would be basically going down and
getting these older
leaves every went down here and getting
getting those out of there now again
these are in pretty good shape
um but normally these would have a lot
of mildew on it you could get those you
could throw them right into the compost
pile and get rid of it and you could do
even a little bit more here you could
cut this um sometimes people are
concerned that when you cut a leaf like
that it leaves this big hole that you
can see right in there and the insects
could get in there and the reality is I
don't think there's going to be any
insects that would cause a problem some
insects might get in there could open it
up for disease maybe but for the most
part what's going to happen is by taking
these leaves off it's going to push all
of this new growth so again this is just
a kind of a way to rejuvenate the plant
um so that you can get more zucchini if
you really want more zucchini later in
the year think about it too you've got
this big root system that's developed so
when you cut these leaves off you've got
a lot of energy coming up from the roots
to push out these new leaves and you can
get you can get a nice Harvest then in
the
fall is that a a practice that you would
recommend and as a professor or I don't
I don't think so I'm just really wanted
to talk about it because people seem to
be recommending it more um it's never
done commercially so a farmer would
never want to do that and I'd also
recommend wear gloves and long sleeves
cuz these leaves can be uh a little
irritating on your arms and your hands
too okay so we just learned about
pruning and how is it done and the way
that we can get more harvesty we need it
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University
on the web at cornell.edu